dustin poirier
and conor mcgregor are fighting
and man this thing really hit somebody
because i know
you know we've been dustin poirier fans
here
we've been underdog fans here we've been
the good fight foundation fans here
since as since we got to know dustin
and i know it's kind of late in his
career that we kind of jumped on the um
on that bayou bad boy bandwagon but uh
but we love him you know we love what he
stands for he's you know he fights for
people
like us you know uh we've always kind of
felt that i feel like and
um and by him coming on the podcast he
gave us a lot of credibility and just
being able to talk to fighters like him
and people who are like him and so um
you know uh what was i saying so it's
just crazy that he's getting to do this
fight because
he held out of the ferguson fight
because it was the money wasn't right
they weren't treating him fairly
and it's interesting to to take a moment
where something is not feeling fair
and to stand up for yourself to stand
your ground and say no
because then once you say no that
whatever the opportunity card it was
coming by
and it's saying hey here here's an
opportunity bucko
and you're saying oh no that's not for
me
and then the cart leaves
and then you just sitting on the porch
and then you just hoping another cart
comes by
and sometimes the cart doesn't come by
even for the good guys the guys who were
trying to do it the right way
the guys who stand up for themselves
even sometimes the cart doesn't come by
so when you see the cart the next cart
that comes
by and that cart is a
[ __ ] irish parade
of senior citizen punching
liquor junkies
named connor effin mcgregor man
dude that is exciting as hell
and it's inspiring that's inspiring
so yeah just to like um have had the
opportunity to talk to dustin in between
those moments when it was like
you know i'm not sure but this i know
that i need to stand up for myself i
need to stay in my ground
and that's just amazing that um it's
inspiring to see that life will reward
uh us and but he also didn't give up at
those moments he stayed
you know kept training to keep training
when you don't even know
if there's gonna be a choo choo that's
crazy
to keep training when you don't even
know if the amtrak is still in business
oh so it's just exciting man it's exci
and you got to come in conor mcgregor
for saying this is some you know
because he's at a level where you know
he's also such a business
so when he touches something it just
generates more business to that thing
so for him to have that part of him that
recognizes
uh hey let's do this
and recognizes when good deeds have gone
undone like i personally feel like they
had gone in the case of
of dustin poirier and tony ferguson in
their in their quest to get just a
better contract deal with ufc
um hats off to him man it's just
it's cool and it's [ __ ] exciting and
everybody wins
everybody wins when dustin wins then it
sets up the trilogy
when uh when um
yeah that's it that's it bro that's it
so i don't know if rogan will let me go
to the fight again man i think i may
kind of
i think i just got too crazy last time
dude i punched my date
uh i [ __ ] put uh mark norman in a
chokehold
you know it was it was a lot
it was a lot man god that was one of the
craziest nights i ever was
part of i had a beautiful date my girl
megan we win it was
fun and it was just like man we were
right there and these guys were
gladiators
that was when dustin poirier was
fighting tony holloway
god and that's when israel adasanya
and kelvin gastelum went at it bruh
like a couple of [ __ ] funky donkeys
bro they went at it
good evening good afternoon and other
times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one
ah